today we're going to talk about whether
you should case brief in law school
what's the answer
no oh do not case brief if you're not
sure what a case brief is here's a quick
overview a case consists of many
different parts some of which are
theoretical and some of which are
actually labeled in the case itself for
example the parties who was involved in
the case the procedural posture how the
case got to the court of appeal was it
an appeal from a trial motion to dismiss
was it appealed from an intermediate
court to the Supreme Court the questions
presented what legal questions did the
court of appeals or the parties were
they interested in the facts the
reasoning the policy or philosophical
questions dissenting opinions dicta etc
etc etc case briefing means that you
summarize those different sections of
the case into some written summary book
briefing the cousin to case briefing is
where you take out a different colored
highlighter and meticulously highlight
each different section in the case
that's why it's also known as rainbow
briefing this process takes hours and
unfortunately this kind of briefing is a
huge waste of time it is just pure busy
work why because you can't use the
information that's found in those cases
on the final it's almost all irrelevant
this is shocking to most people but
think about how you're going to use
cases on a final exam in law school we
have a whole video on what you should
know about law school exams and we'll
put a link down below but in summary a
law school exam is a test of applying
the law just like a real lawyer would in
in the real world you pretend to be a
lawyer for one side and then mentally
flip to being the lawyer for the other
side you're constantly arguing for
claims and counterclaims and defenses in
those circumstances there is no room at
all for most of the information that you
put in a case brief when you're arguing
like a lawyer in court you don't care
about the
is presented in the court of appeal you
don't really even care about the
procedural posture except in rare cases
and like Civil Procedure even the
reasoning and the rationale and policy
it's not helpful in a courtroom setting
what you will use on a final exam are
one of two things one either the bear
recitation of the facts or a bright-line
legal rule for example let's say on the
exam that you have a simple hypo about a
man who drives through an intersection
while the light is yellow and they hit a
pedestrian in class you read two cases
in the first case a person is liable
when they drove through an intersection
while the light turned red in another
case the court simply held that a driver
is liable for any inherently dangerous
activity using those two cases you might
argue that the man is liable by drawing
an analogy to the red light case you'd
say something like driving through an
intersection with a yellow light is
similar to driving through on a red
light and therefore that person is
liable or you might say that based on
the rule of the second case driving
through an intersection with a yellow
light is an inherently dangerous
activity and therefore they are liable
or you might argue the opposite it's not
analogous to the red light case or it
doesn't fit the rule that driving
through a yellow light is an inherently
dangerous activity and therefore he's
not liable but the way you use cases is
that you use the rule or you use the
facts and that is it it's why it's so
bad to brief a case you're just putting
down and recording irrelevant
information that you are not going to be
able to mobilize on your final exam so
why would people do this busy work
because it's the kind of work that seems
like it might be helpful it's the kind
of discrete activity that you can check
off your to-do list you can set a goal
and you can do it in terms of case
briefing and during the regular semester
there just simply aren't that many
things that you can
Koff your list of things to do without
midterms or papers or pop quizzes there
are just no indication during the
regular semester that you're on the
right track you feel largely adrift
without hard deadlines and discrete
tasks except of course for the final
exam at the end so case briefing
provides a sense of accomplishment but
unfortunately that is an illusory
feeling your only resource in law school
is time if you give it up by studying
the wrong things you're dead in the
water don't get sucked in to briefing
your cases it's just a waste of time
instead focus on distilling the
information just use the parts of the
case that you're actually going to use
on your exam put it in a good outline
and start taking practice tests apply
the information apply the cases that you
get and you'll see that case breathing
is just a total waste of time
so don't give up your time without a
fight focus on the things that matter
and cut out the time wasters and you'll
do much better on your next law school
exam hey hold on if you want to spend
less time studying and get better grades
you're in luck
we've put together a free ebook the
ultimate guide for Law School cases just
click the link below to download it some
of our best strategies on reading cases
and half the time while better preparing
for finals and I promise you will never
case free again just click below also if
you like this video please subscribe to
our Channel we come out with new videos
on how to crush law school all the time
thanks from everyone here at legal eagle
[Music]